ソフトクリームの持つてってあるじゃないですか続入稿ンっていうんですけどあれって
さあ餅ってじゃん間も連ならシュガーコーンとか味が付いてると話がまた別になるとこ
ですけどもこの普通のコーンアイスについているただのコーンてこれ
なんだのではこちらもってっていいのはわかってるんですけどこの公って存在意義が
吹っ飛ぶっこにいない釣りが出来てなくて本当に愛す送るための取っ手だけの城をで
あり味も今朝のあるわけでもなくこれマジでもう
う鍋読むソフトグリがこの没あの役割以外はモールなんで打ってもあまり感覚がないと
思ってるんだよ僕ってことは無限肉いるんじゃない
ちょっとゲームこの持ち手のコーンカップ200何個を準備しました
全部クイルズね私はこんなに軽いものだったら多分上にくる撃つに空気でコーンカップ
何コケるがちょっと試してみようと思いますマジこれが本当に意味のない代物であっ
たら僕は麦受けることができる的にこの200個程度で僕がウェットかなってたら
まあまあ
いきますよし僕ももう食わせていただきましていただきます
[音楽]
味がねぇ
1本
えっ
すごいなんかに告ったんですけど全然お腹が膨れませんこれまず向けに来る人あるぞ
これ
えっ
4つ目にして早くも気づいたことがありますこれなんかあまりなんか保本の病気がし
ます a でも砂糖使われてないんだけど
次これ
ああああああ
福江ば食うほど味の宇佐川ちゃんパターンとこれは結婚って美味いのな
全然息はこれ
くれるぞ
ん
うん
まあ
いやー
なんか別にお腹がいっぱいとかってわけじゃないですけど顎が疲れますタブのが本当に
愛知てバリバリバリバリ辛いけどまだ
ok です
ノードズバッえっ
[音楽]
[拍手]
あきちゃこんなビッグ歌っていったなぁ20僕ぐらいけどちょっと分けますねです
で女川復全然食えるんでもっと舌でいこうと思います
あの味に飽きました今31個くらい食べたんですけども
まずないしお腹もまだてねくれるんですけど切っやっぱり今っていうのはアイスがない
とやっぱコーナーせいじゃないなと場面でちょっとアイスの設定食べていきましょう
えっ
うんうん
ああああああねぇ倍速てなんぼだな
ちょっとこの作戦で食っています
[音楽]
エッジ
まず家を出てきたなぜかあいつくれるね血がついて全く分からないそれコーンが鋭すぎ
て縁が出血してるんだと思います
苦しい
[音楽]
です嫁
ice cream with いた結構大きい訳なんですけども大分ないです
ツクッター
[音楽]
思ってん
うっ
もう無理かも現状元気や
人間砂利は全然しだ
さあいけると思ったらねぇくれなかった範囲がいくつかありましてまずね味に飽きて
しまいます本当にでもやはりコーンなりの味がありまして
市場にを開きいたしましたここに知念はもう食いたくないと思います味に飽きたらって
いうのは700キロかぶるやるアイスほぼくってしまいましたそれでちょっとお腹も
膨れてしまったかつ保温がすごい一体このままだといいんです
けどがこういう家くっつくになったモノを口に運ぶと刺さっちゃって血が出ました
はまっ徳江たと思うんですけどもの僕は取れず
57戸で結界でした全部食べると思ったわけですけど
女でした2寄せでした
th
me
ああああああ
バッハ